Scotland's waters are full of fish
trawlers from many EU countries come
here for the bountiful catches Peterhead
is Scotland's biggest fishing port 500
trawlers used to be based here now there
are just 80 George Leslie is a deckhand
his father was also a fisherman but lost
his job George says the entire fishing
tradition here has been destroyed
fishermen were getting fed the
decommissioned Atwoods I don't know why
all that fishermen who didn't have sons
coming behind them decommission in their
boots
so he was getting paid the decommission
your book that some fishermen it
decommissioned our boys have rebuilt new
woods
George Leslie doesn't trust Scotland's
First Minister Nicola Sturgeon she wants
another referendum on independence from
the United Kingdom George thinks the
Scottish economy is too weak to sustain
an independent nation Nicola Sturgeon
doesn't like the fisherman
she's not she doesn't bet you do not
want the benefit us she's all for the
oil
miles finished some former fishermen
found work in the oil industry but as
the oil price tanked many lost their
jobs again
Peter heads fish market is right by the
docks
[Music]
good day five or six thousand boxes of
cod hake Pike and shrimp are auctioned
here
most of the catch is sold within the EU
but EU fishing quotas mean not as much
may be caught and therefore sold or
exported as the fisherman would like
that's why most are looking forward to
brexit
EU has devastated our industry fishermen
markets are aligned of fishermen
processors industry communities has been
absolutely devastated 60% of our fleet
has been scrapped to make way to
accommodate the European fleet under
equal access to Corman Resort Scotland's
fishermen complained that Norway and
Iceland can negotiate their fishing
quotas while their country cannot what
they don't acknowledge is that the EU
decided to reduce the number of trawlers
in order to protect fish stocks the EU
also paid fishermen to scrap their boats
while smaller trawler operators gave up
the larger outfits benefited local
competition is fierce newer trawler
models have a greater range and can
catch more fish Scottish fishermen tend
not to mention that peterhead Port
Authority has the numbers to prove that
things are not as bad as many fishermen
say since 2014
each year the fishing has increased the
numbers has increased the boxes has
increased last year we were up a hundred
and fifty thousand boxes in the previous
year and the year before that and 2015
and 216 we was up about 90 thousand
boxes the harbour is being redeveloped
and a new fish market is being built
both projects receive funding from the
European Union
to be a member of the EU the United
Kingdom has paid a handsome sum every
year to be part of that club so in
effect we were just getting our own
money back brexit supporters say
membership isn't worth the cost
the fishermen want the divorce deal to
improve their situation if tariffs the
unworkable then we will have to demand
on our government that they find
opportunities and new markets globally
so it may not always be in the best
interests of Europe to be very hard on
the UK when it comes to negotiation the
fishing industry in Peter head may be
booming but 35 percent of the workforce
don't have any professional training
there's been no serious structural
realignment of the economy in this
region brexit is also an issue at this
fish factory while the UK government in
London wants to slash immigration here
they want to keep their foreign workers
one third of the staff are from Romania
and Poland without them everything would
grind to a halt
and on George Leslie's trawler local
fishermen have been almost entirely
replaced by foreign deckhands who earn
much less
[Music]
my clues for a Scottish fishermen have
been under pressure because of
globalization and local competition they
think everything will be better once the
UK quits the EU the UK is certainly
heading out of the EU but Scotland might
vote to leave the UK and seek to stay in
or rejoin the EU conditions may continue
to be stormy for Scotland's fishermen